got it all right
um so um we will move on to
our first speaker eleanor hannah
who will speak to us about insights from
the human visual system
lateral inhibition implemented in python
so eleanor i will hand it over to you
hey phyllis um let me go ahead and share
my screen
so
let's see um
okay uh
what do you folks see did they see a
powerpoint presentation or they see
a background picture of a dog we see
presenter view for the powerpoint
oh that's not right i want you to know
my secrets
at the top if you click the display
settings drop down you can choose
swap uh presenter view it's at the
top of the screen
the top of the second
in the black bar to the right of show
task bar
i'm not even sure what we're talking
about that's
again off to a great start
it's right on the top of the uh
powerpoint
oh yeah it is covered up by the zoom
thing that's the problem
yeah there you go hey there you go
here we go all right okay um
it's about the level of confidence you
should get used to for the rest of this
presentation
um so hi everybody my name is ellen or
hannah
i am a data scientist
at veracast formerly volasus sorry about
the
incorrect uh moniker here um
and i work on the consumer graph team um
working pulling
uh insights about our different users
together
in new and useful ways for our clients
and i came to data science
via a phd in psychology and neuroscience
from duke university um back in 2019
um and during my graduate study
i became very interested in a lot of
paradigms that are really useful in data
science or at least interesting
for data science and i want to talk
about one of my
favorite things that wasn't really part
of my dissertation research but it was
part of
something that i had to teach to do
undergrads frequently
and i think that by looking at this kind
of thing we get a little bit of
insight into how biological models have
informed
artificial neural networks and just
computer science in general
um and also maybe can give us a chance
to kind of
experience that sort of like playful
spirit that brings us to data science a
lot of the time
um so i'm gonna start off with an
optical illusion
um that's how you start off all of your
undergraduate psychology courses
um so this is called the mock band
illusion this is an illusion that was
actu
actually isolated in the 19th century
and um when you observe this
it could either look you might say that
it looks like bands of the
same color um across each band itself
or you might say that it looks like each
individual band is kind of doing a
gradient
it might look for instance like this is
a little bit
darker than this area right here i hope
people can see my cursor but basically
if you're just looking within a band it
looks it might look like
as you go from left to right it gets a
little bit darker um
but in reality uh that's not the case
it's just one solid color all the way
across
and the question is why this is
happening why is it that there would be
some kind of setup in our eye that would
make this misfire for us and the
mock band illusion is basically an
instance where one of the biological
shortcuts that our nervous system takes
um has gone wrong
and this shortcut is usually very good
and it's a shortcut
that has to do with some
unfortunate evolutionary inheritances
that we got from our ancestors about how
the eye
works so when you see something
um light passes through the lens of your
eye
um and then it has to travel through
some
some vitreous humor this is a jelly-like
tissue um just kind of some some goopy
substance
before it finally lands on the back of
your eye where the
the neural representation of the image
begins to take place
and much like when you shine uh the beam
of a flashlight
through uh say a swimming pool if you
can envision that
you get some distortion you get some
blurriness so you might have
one kind of image coming through uh
reflected light in this particular kind
of configuration coming
through your lens through the pupil and
then once it passes through the vitreous
humor you end up with something that's a
little bit blurrier
so essentially the the main biological
problem that we're confronted with is
that we lose resolution in images
and this is bad for us we need to
to some certain fitness related extent
we need to be able to detect edges for
one thing and we need to be able to get
a certain amount of information about
our visual environment so that we can
form
concepts about what things look like and
what environments
certain figures might emerge in
it's very important for us to be able to
correct this mistake for a variety
of evolutionary reasons um so
the solution that our nervous system has
come up with is lateral inhibition
it's a way of dialing up the contrast at
boundaries
of luminance so rather than this is an
extremely
two pixel low resolution retinal image
um we get our visual er neurons are set
up in such a way
that we get um lighter so on the on the
lighter side of
this 2 pixel boundary luminance we get
even lighter at the at the boundary than
the rest of the block
and we get even darker than the rest of
the block on the darker side
essentially our visual neurons make the
contrast dial up
so rather than this again you get this
um so how does this process work
basically you can think of there being
two phases to this
we start with light coming in and
stimulating so again passes through the
lens and then stimulates the
photoreceptors
um at the back of the eye um that's rods
and cones we're only going to be dealing
with rods today
um and then there's sort of like once we
just get this
raw blurry information into our eyes
there's
the computational level which is a
series of layers of neurons
um that are basically set up
in such a way that they will
end up creating that contrast um
just a quick primer on how a neuronal
signaling to kind of
make this a little bit clearer and get
some background information
your nervous system is basically made up
of a multitude of chain reactions
between
neurons each link in that chain is a
neuron
and a neuron can either it can excite
the neuron next to it in the chain or it
can
inhibit it um if neuron a has an
excitatory relationship with neuron b
um then when it fires it releases
excitatory neurotransmitters into the
space between them into the synapse
that will make neuron be more likely to
fire which means that you'll see
neuron be firing more rapidly um if
neuron a
is inhibiting neuron b then neuron a
will fire a neurotransmitter into the
synapse that makes neuron be less likely
to fire which means
that you'll see neuron b slow down or
even stop its firing
and neurons don't only synapse onto one
next neuron down the chain sometimes a
neuron will be
firing off neurotransmitters at lots of
different neurons downstream
and they could have excitatory
relationships with those downstream
neurons
inhibitory relationships or even kind of
a mix of both
and that's the most interesting case
that's actually the foundation for for
lateral inhibition here um so uh
we if you you know we're a data science
crowd you've probably
done a little bit of looking at an
artificial neural network in your day
and it's it's the same basic principle
um so here each circle would represent
an artificial neuron um and a neuron in
layer one
might have a relationship with multiple
neurons in layer two
um some of which could be excitatory and
some of which could be inhibitory
and so on um and this is essentially how
the nervous system is frequently
organized as well in these
layers basically um so that's kind of
like the
uh extremely quick version of
uh 101 neuro horse um let's return now
to the
the problem we're trying to solve with
lateral inhibition um
so how does this particular
configuration of excitatory inhibitory
connections across these layers
end up unblurring an image for us um so
let's break it down into an extremely
abstract example
um we've got here uh
cylinders that represent rods so again
we have the two kinds of photoreceptors
you've probably heard of rods and cones
cones see color rods are the ones that
see high precision grayscale
they're the ones we're going to be
looking at all they ever care about is
how much
light is hitting them at once this is
that photoreceptor layer we talked about
they're the first line of defense that
just gets the reflected light
through the vitreous humor it's all
blurry it's the first thing that we see
um this photoreceptor layer will then
talk to a subsequent layer of
uh neurons it's the retinal ganglion
neurons you don't need to know that
specifically
but there are multiple connections
between any given rod
and for this very simple example
a couple of different neurons in the
subsequent level
and it it's sort of the same pattern as
we go down to the next layer so this
this top layer of
neurons they might each have a couple of
different connections
to the neurons in the second layer and
so on
um and let's say you've got a really
simple visual field here we've got
again just sort of two different things
in your universe you've got
one really dim plane
in your visual field and then to the
right of it you've got a much brighter
plane
um thanks to powerpoint this this looks
a little bit
faded but think of this as just being a
very bright gray and this being a very
shadowed
dark lap of luminance
so let's try now to represent this
abstractly with numbers
by saying that that bright square we saw
before on the right
is 40 units of luminance that are
hitting each of these
rods on the right and that that dim
square is 20 units of luminance that's
hitting that
dim square on the left um so
here comes the lateral inhibition any
given
rod in this particular setup has one
excitatory connection
with one sort of partner
neuron in the next layer and it really
wants to convey
i'm going to be using anthropomorphic
terms because i've taught this
particular concept maybe five times and
it's actually easiest to grok
when you are using anthropomorphic terms
so i apologize for kind of the soap
opera i'm about to spin out for you
um but this this any given rod
has that one kind of excitatory pairing
with its one special
neuron downstream where it's going to
try to convey exactly the amount of
luminance that it saw
so this rod right here the the second
from the left
is trying to send 20 units of luminance
down to its little partner neuron
um the the rub about lateral inhibition
is that
the neighbors to either side of that rod
so
lateral to that rod are going to
sneakily be sabotaging its
special cell they're going to be sending
inhibitory signal
um that will then be integrated by this
guy um
how much inhibitory signal um so there
is an
inhibition constant i've arbitrarily
decided right now on
just 0.25 we'll talk later about how you
might tune that or scale that
but for now we'll say in the retina
there is just one inhibition constant
that all of the different rods have and
basically what it does
is it's a way to scale the amount that
it's being excited
by the rod um so we
are getting 20 so let's let's look at
this now third
from the left rod it's getting 20
units of luminance hitting it and which
means that when it tries to sabotage its
neighbor
we will scale that 20 down by
multiplying it by 0.25
and we're going to subtract that from
what's being synapsed onto this little
green guy
so we are seeing 20 units of excitation
and then from either side we're seeing
10 units of inhibition which results in
this cell seeing
just 10 units of luminance um
the same general principle happens for
the brighter thing um the brighter
square i should say
um we see this this second from the
the right rod is getting 40 units of
luminance that it's trying to send to
its partner neuron
um but then the the sabotage from this
the neighbors the lateral inhibition is
going to scale their
units of luminance down by 0.25
and subtract that from all of the the
information that's being integrated onto
this
neuron which results in 20 units of
luminance
so far we've just seen that lateral
inhibition is or this
configuration of connections is really
good at just decreasing the overall
amount of luminance and that is
something that happens
um but it gets interesting when you have
a rod that has
um a neighbor on uh with basically
different
amounts of luminance on either side so
here we've got this this third from the
left
rod um has a partner has a sorry
has a neighbor on the left that has the
same amount of luminance
is being exposed to the same amount of
luminance that it is and it has a
neighbor on the right that is being
illuminated
much more um so it's going to send to
its partner neuron
20 units of luminance or 20 an
excitation that is
related to 20 units of luminance its
neighbor's going to be sabotaging it
just a little
um by by one quarter of its citation
um but then its other neighbor to the
right
um has been stimulated a lot more so the
the quarter of its
stimulation that it will sabotage this
this third from
the left green guy by is much higher
which means that
ultimately when we've taken into account
the excitatory information
from its partner rod and the inhibitory
sabotage
signal from the the rods to the neighbor
of this main rod we end up with a much
lower luminance we end up with just
five um and interestingly when you've
got
you see a spike when you perform the
same calculation
on the side that has the higher
luminance overall
um we see 40 units of excitation coming
this way
minus 10 minus 5 25 units
what this essentially causes is a
brighter amount
there's basically more luminance at the
border on the bright side
and less luminance on the border on the
dark side
um and ultimately when we
perform that calculation across a lot of
different parts of the visual field at
once
we rather than having this kind of like
blocky blurry low resolution image
we end up with increased contrast and
that's a way that we can try
to correct for the problem of
having light shine in through the the
vitreous humor in the eye
so that's the first part that's kind of
like the
the background that you need for the
biological
information about lateral inhibition um
does anyone have any questions at this
point
um about how that works um so that we
can move on
to the notebook
i'm looking in the chat um
cool yes thank you mike i'll look into
that um
so
good okay so this is telling me the
answer i need to know so
um do people see can you post in the
chat i've got my
my zoom all screwed up here um could
somebody say if they see a notebook that
says 2d puppies and 3d flowers
yep that's right great um so this is the
next part this is
uh me trying to take the insight from
the biological
computational model and apply it to
first of all to recreate it in python
and then to see if again in kind of that
playful interdisciplinary spirit that
draws us to data science
try to see if we can use it for a
application that is not image processing
um
so first i want to kind of talk about
how we might take this
this abstraction of a biological model
and put it in
a python notebook um so again we
basically this is this is sort of a
replication of what might happen this is
my dog jones
she's very cute this is when she was a
puppy um when she used to sleep now she
just barks all the time
um so this let's say this is kind of the
raw light reflection coming
before it even hits the vitreous humor
this is the very first signal
um once it's passed through the vitreous
humor in my eye and hit the retina at
the back of it it's all blurry so
oh dear how can i see my sweet puppy um
we correct for this again using lateral
inhibition
and the way i implemented it for this
particular
application was i kind of borrowed from
well i didn't really borrow it was more
that the image processing world has
borrowed from this already and i
selected one of the things that they
borrowed
um i convolved the matrix of luminances
that you could represent the image as
with a kernel that would represent
lateral inhibition so uh basically
when i was showing you before um either
the the sort of like constant by which
you would be inhibiting
the neighbors um that's kind of right
here that's the subtracted
constant of of whatever is at the side
of this
um we'll talk about how we would kind of
select an
inhibition constant in a second but
essentially what we would do is we would
convolve
this lateral inhibition kernel across
this
uh image so right now let's say that
this is kind of
similar to the example that i showed in
the powerpoint this right here would be
a sort of a darker block
um and this right here would be kind of
a lighter block where the the
numbers are representing the amount of
brightness the luminance
um so essentially
if we were to perform this action um
there's a couple of other little steps
we would need to take um
i mentioned that and a neuron can
excite another neuron or inhibit another
neuron um
when we're looking at lateral inhibition
specifically
once we've gotten to that the output of
that little green cell
um that's an excitatory output so we
can't essentially
we can't go below zero
so the first step is to convolve this
matrix of luminances with this kernel
the second step is to replace all the
negative values with zero
um and then as you'll see
basically what that results in is that
overall decrease in luminance this is as
the
the sabotage by the neighboring pixels
gets
more and more a higher and higher
proportion of the original
uh excitation um there's that overall
decrease in luminance but we see this
kind of like increase
in brightness on the bright side and
increase in darkness on the dark side um
but the third step that we're missing
here so we've convolved we've gotten rid
of all the negatives because that
doesn't make any sense and we've
replaced them with zero
um and now we need to kind of handle
this sort of like
overall darkness we need to amplify the
signal um
oh i actually put that later in the
notebook i'm sorry um
i want to talk a little bit about how we
would select this inhibition constant
now
um how much should we want the
neighboring pixels or neurons to be sort
of sabotaging and inhibiting each other
um we can pick at least an upper limit
of 0.125 for this case um
and you might have already figured out
why that's the case
um i'll show you right now when i ran
just i looked at the maximum
and minimum luminances of a laterally
inhibited version of an image at a
higher and higher
inhibition constant we got to all zeros
when we get to 0.125 and the reason
behind that
is that if you look back at this kernel
there's basically eight squares
uh adjacent to this this middle square
that is sort of the origin of the
convolution
um that are all getting this this
negative information so 0.125
is 1 8 it's the point at which the dark
and light
are in the middle block are the same
value
um if you go higher than .125 then
essentially you're going to be switching
brightness and darkness you're going to
get a photo negative um
so just to kind of like show you what
that would look like um
we would basically have something that
looked
like this right here at the side but it
would be bright
on the inside where the dog is and dark
on the little edges
um so
back to this amplification that i
mentioned was part of this
um it sort of helps us first of all to
see
the the difference um but
sorry i rearranged this notebook at the
11th hour and i'm trying to figure out
what i meant to say
um right so there's
an additional step of amplification of
the signal to basically brighten it up
so that we can see it again
um and i essentially for this
demonstration um resorted to
the automatic auto scaling default and
matplotlib where it
scales everything to from zero to one um
and the reason for that is that we don't
actually need to identify the constant
by which we would amplify that first
signal
um we basically we know that in the
nervous system amplification
is uh one of the most common things that
layers of neurons do
we know that some other population of
neurons is going to have a configuration
that takes that laterally inhibited
image
and then just dials it up for us um and
it's not
especially important for the downstream
parts of the brain
that it be the same amount of luminance
that came in
what's important is that it is enough of
a contrast in information that whatever
we are going to send that image
representation to
in the brain if we're going to set it to
some kind of memory
or try to activate some kind of concept
or whatever we just need it to have the
code that will activate that memory or
that concept or whatever
um essentially all you need to know is
it's not especially important for
the result of the lateral inhibition
process to be
vertical as far as luminance it doesn't
need to be as bright as the outside
again it just needs to be something that
the rest of our machinery downstream
knows what to do with um so what that
means is that we don't need to decide on
a scaling constant for this
we can just have matplotlib scale it up
for us so that we can see it
and know that there is some arbitrary
constant by which or semi-arbitrary
constant by which we amplify
the image um all this to say
that when you try to pick an inhibition
constant
um so this is again getting higher and
higher on the inhibition constant
in real life it's getting darker and
darker
if we let matplotlib just scale it up
for us
so we can kind of essentially just shine
the light a little brighter on
the result of our lateral inhibition um
we see something a little disappointing
it's an extremely subtle if maybe even
undetectable change
uh until we get to that equalizing point
um where the dark
side and the light side are the same
value
and the only thing that is different is
the contrast
um so it turns out math like when you
look at the matrices themselves these
numbers are different but it sure is a
subtle difference
um when we've turned the lights on
enough to
see what those contrasts even were but
if you remember if you think back to the
slide it wasn't just
one layer of green dots it was various
layers so there's there's many different
layers at which lateral inhibition takes
place essentially
we perform it over and over so what
happens if we
iterate this lateral inhibition process
um it's a little weird looking but there
is
a much less subtle change so
basically this is the blur that we came
in with um
let's say this is this first layer of
green dots second layer of green dots
by the time we get to three iterations
of lateral inhibitions say this is the
the representation the neural coding
that got passed on to
more complex visual areas in the brain
um we have
something that looks a little bit closer
to the original image we we
have certainly we have edges that are a
little bit clearer
um whereas before this kind of blur
might not be readily identifiable as a
dog
we see enough of kind of the ear and the
eye and the
other ear to sort of be able to link
this
image representation to our existing
concepts of dogs
so this means that we've solved the the
problem
presented by the vitreous humor on our
eye to a certain extent
we have been able to get around the
problem of blurriness
and even though it doesn't look exactly
like the original image
we've been able to make it so that the
important stuff the kind of
the the edges essentially are there and
we can use that information
for a lot of our important day-to-day
neural processing
um when we want to try to
tune these parameters so again trying to
approach this from a data science
perspective
it would be great to try to tune these
parameters
in kind of an automated way but the
problem is that
finding a cost function for how close we
get
the resulting image to the original
picture of
non-blurry jonesy the puppy it was very
hard to find
such a cost function so i tried looking
just at the euclidean distance
it didn't end up mapping on to what
looked to this human observer like the
closest
match um i tried also looking at uh
comparing the different frequency
distributions of
luminances again it ended up with
something that didn't really look like
my puppy so what i ended up doing
was preparing a grid that modulated both
the inhibition constant so making it a
sharper and sharper
inhibition by the neighboring pixels and
also modulating the number of iterations
so that would be the
the number of times that this lateral
inhibition was performed
um roughly corresponding to the number
of layers of neurons that we had
so when you do this you know you can
kind of visually inspect it
um some interesting things pop out um we
see
that when we are both iterating more
and sabotaging more inhibiting more
there is
more and more artifact that we get in
the image so i mentioned before that
it's not
necessarily very important to our
downstream
um neural processes that we get it
exactly right we just need the important
stuff
but we start getting some noise as well
once we reach past a certain part so
here um
if we look at the inhibition constant of
0.123 at four iterations
we see just sort of like a patch we've
lost a lot of the important signal
within the dog
we're seeing stuff that isn't there in
the original image as far as the way the
sofa that she's lying on looks we're
seeing this kind of like
um biased cross hatch pattern that
isn't present in the actual picture
it's just kind of a result of the fact
probably that
it's laid out on this very like square
grid
um not exactly sure even what that
results from um but basically you can
kind of
for this very simple demo you can
look at a grid like this where you've
tuned these two parameters
and you can pick some parameters that
kind of map to
your own human cost function of what
seems
most closely to match your puppy um
these are my favorite parameters this is
using an inhibition constant uh right
below the
the equalizing constant so it's
inhibiting almost as much as you can get
on
either side um before it starts to
switch
white for black um and uh at three
iterations
we get a pretty decent there is a little
bit of our
artifact again so um but we get a pretty
decent reconstruction of the original
image so here we've got this is the
original
the middle is the the raw image that has
just passed through all of the vitreous
group
and this is what we our nervous system
could reasonably be expected to try to
do something with
um i want to point out a couple of
things that are interesting so in the
top right corner of this
um you can see kind of the the pattern
of the pillow
that is behind jonesy and the original
photograph
um which is like essentially pretty lost
in the blurry image
we get not only um you know we might be
able to use
this kind of like general gradient
information that hit
our retina for something but if we
wanted to do something suppose it was
very important for our evolutionary
fitness to know the pattern of the
pillow behind the dog maybe there's
something very interesting to us
about this kind of like arc pattern and
the kind of
detail on it the ornamentation the
lateral inhibition
has kind of restored that a little bit
um so essentially
that's i was i was glad to be able to
get
pretty close to the original puppy um
if we wanted to kind of sum up this part
of it
uh we know that it essentially what you
should
what you should remember for the test is
that lateral inhibition
of a distorted blurry image doesn't give
us a totally perfect
reconstruction but it gets close enough
for government work essentially
um and we by taking the three steps of
convolving a matrix of luminances with
the kernel where
the matrix of luminances is just the
original
um set of brightnesses that we get
per pixel with the kernel that is
all some proportion of
one below 0.125 um negative with a 1 in
the center
um and then we replace all of the
negative values of that convolved matrix
with 0 and then we
amplify to some extent which is
basically for convenience more than
anything else
then we can reproduce what happens in
the
the visual system and end up with
something close to my puppy
um so that's
kind of the first part i'm gonna start
straying into some
um less image processing
oriented stuff in the latter part um
before i do that does anyone have any
questions that they could maybe post in
the chat or
[Music]
say out loud with your voice too before
i move on
there is one question in the chat now
about whether lateral inhibition
is similar to unsharp masking
i'm not specifically familiar with
unsharp masking but i wouldn't be
surprised
so there's uh a lot of i think i
briefly glossed over this um
there's a lot of image processing stuff
that
we do in that we've kind of expounded on
a lot in
that involves convolution on a kernel
like this
and the i remember
seeing something extremely close to the
lateral inhibition kernel that i came up
with here
um in being labeled as edge detection
so with that they did the amplification
as well as the
um the inhibition in one step it's like
a three by three matrix of negative one
with an eight in the middle um so
we one thing i always like to kind of
talk about when it comes to the
evolution
of the nervous system is that we didn't
get it optimal
we got something that was like pretty
close this
this kernel that doesn't that we have
that i
that i showed above i'll scroll up just
so i'm not just trying to describe
an image with with my words this this
lateral inhibition kernel here
um which is what we think are our visual
neurons are doing it's not optimal
um if we wanted to really do really good
edge detection we would put an
8 here we'd have the amplification and
the inhibition happening in one step
and we have come up with a variety of
different other kinds of kernels that
will have different effects they could
blur they could
um i again i'll look into unsharp
masking but i imagine that has its own
kernel to convolve on um but it's kind
of neat to see
that that sort of innovation in
artificial image processing
could be based on something that was we
might have gleaned from a biological
model um okay
so with that i am going to move on from
puppies to flowers
um so i was really interested in the
possibility that
i love me a good k-means cluster um i
think the first thing that i thought was
interesting about data science was the
idea that you can just
shake a bunch of data points out and
based on some features they would kind
of
decide what group they belong to once
you've given them a little bit of
guidance
um so i thought that it would be
really neat to try to apply lateral
inhibition
to problems that involve putting points
in multi-dimensional space
um there's a very small amount of work
that has been done to investigate this
idea before
if you're interested um you can contact
me after the meeting and i can send you
this notebook for one but then also i
can link you to this um
one single example that i saw of a study
that did this um but essentially i would
like to just kind of see
if basically lateral inhibition can be
used to make a scatter plot
easier to do a cluster on um so i
specifically just for this experiment i
looked at the famous iris data set it's
99 certain to me that everyone knows
what that is but
in the event that you aren't familiar
with the iris data set
it is 50 observations of three different
varieties of iris the setosa
iris the virginica and the versacolor um
and it also
in this data set they provide four
features of which we will only look at
three because that's easier to plot
um so the length of the steeple the
width of the siebel
and the width of the petal of the iris
and the idea is that this is a really
good data set for sort of new data
scientists to use um
because it has a nice division
between these different varieties of
iris
based on these features um so
this is just kind of like a quick
example of the kind of thing that we
would look at
um so again just looking at three of
these four features
when we plot this set of observations in
a three-dimensional space
um we can see that they're kind of
clustered kind of close together they're
they're different enough in this
three-dimensional space that it's
not too hard to tell them apart but
still they they kind of overlap
as you can see um some of the the
setosas
well satoshi is pretty good but
especially i want you to bear in mind
that
versacolor and virginia tend to kind of
overlap there there's sort of
one really big glob whereas setosa is
very dense
and it's a little bit farther apart from
these other two
um so let's say that we
are botanists from
a long time ago before there had been
any sort of assignment of of classes
on irises um and we would we were trying
to develop a taxonomy of iris varieties
ourselves
we could use a some kind of unsupervised
approach
such as a k-means clustering paradigm
to cluster these 150 unspecified irises
into three different groups based on
their similarity on these features
and when we do that um these are the
clusters
again so this is unsupervised there's no
direct relationship between say cluster
zero and setosa here or anything like
that
but essentially we see just breaking
down by differences in color
that there's a little cluster down here
that looks like it's kind of all to
itself that looks like it's probably
setosa
and we see um you know it's it's not
a terrible it's it's not a terrible
mapping between this
middle guy here and versacolor
and this rightmost topmost guy here and
virginica um and if we wanted to try
to see how well these alternate universe
botanists did
with their completely data-driven
approach to
converging on what actual botanists
decided when they were creating a
taxonomy of irises
um we can kind of check this in a back
doorway we could
train a random forest classifier to
solely use the
not to ignore the information about
steeple length
and sepal width and and pedal with um
just look at the assignment of any given
iris to the cluster that we came up with
when we did a k-means clustering
algorithm based on these features
um so we're getting rid of the direct
the numbers themselves about
sepals and whatnot we're just saying
that once we have used
these simple data to
create three clusters we want to see if
being in cluster zero means you're most
likely to be in
setosa um and when we do that
it works really pretty well especially
again for setosa which is really easy to
predict on these three features
um basically what this is telling us is
that clusters
that we derived from those three
features are really good
at kind of distinguishing
[Music]
setosa from all of them but then also
distinguishing versa color from
virginica
it's not perfect um but we can see that
it's it's very good
um so let's say
we wanted it to be even better um
we have a problem in this
multi-dimensional space
that kind of looks you know i've
generalized this out to a third
dimension
but even just kind of like flattening
this to two dimensions in your head
um this is sort of a similar kind of
problem to blurry vision
in a way we've got these overlapping
clusters there are different
levels of you know it's this is actually
a
really beautiful picture of it there's a
big density of setosa here it looks
and the way that matplotlib plots this
is
it starts it out with kind of like an
alpha already and then you've got
overlapping ones they're
a little bit darker because you've
overlapped one
dim one with another dim one so
essentially what this is representing is
like an increase in luminance
um so you've got this sort of like
brighter
set here and then a little bit dimmer
but you know brighter over here
and uh sort of like dimmer overall
because it is
it is more uh it is more spread out
in virginica we've got what amounts to
different
levels of luminance um or at least you
can formulate it in that way
so what if we took advantage of
what we know about lateral inhibition to
try to dial
up the contrast between versa color and
virginica
um so when we do that uh
i'm happy to delve into the way that i
accomplish this specifically but i'm
going to go over it at a very high level
here
whereas before we had
uh basically we had an image matrix
right there for us by uploading an image
matrix we had to create
an image here um the irs data set just
has each row corresponds to one iris
um but in theory for this to work we
would need the entire three dimensional
space to be mapped
so we would need um basically for every
combination every option that we had for
sepal length we would need a point in
the matrix
and every option in petal width we would
need another option
so i represented the multi-dimensional
space as a 3d matrix
at each coordinate triad
the it was a zero if there were no
irises that
had that particular set of features all
together
but if you had say two irises that had a
a petal width of of a and a
sepal length of b and a sepal width of c
then point a b c in the matrix uh would
be two
you know i unfortunately wrote the a
different thing that i said
um that's if no irises had that
particular set of features then we would
say that in that three-dimensional
matrix the the point would be zero um
if there were two irises with a petal
width of d
a sepal width of e and a sepal length of
f then
the the point uh d e f would
be weighted at two etcetera so it
basically corresponds
to the number of observations that fall
into that particular
uh triad of coordinates um
so we've got that first thing that
corresponds to the image
we've just made it in three dimensions
here um and we can't use the same
exact kernel we used for 2d lateral
inhibition because we're in 3d now
um so if you remember up at the tippy
top um
this it only needs to have the same
number of dimensions as the the input
image
and now this is 2d we need a 3d kernel
so that essentially you can generalize
this to a
3x3 kernel of negative c's
um with at the very center um
you would have the one again so
um otherwise the process is essentially
the same
um we would first we first convolve that
three by three matrix onto the
three-dimensional
scatter plot matrix and we take all of
those negative values
that don't make a lot of biological
sense and we replace them with zero
i did amplify as well just to kind of
scale it for human interpretability but
as far as
like that doesn't especially matter in
terms of
what we were doing this for and what
matters is the kind of like
the the distance on the range that we
have when we're doing a k-means
clustering analysis like this
so essentially what i did was
i i ran
uh that lateral inhibition in 3d um and
what i ended up with is essentially
a different luminance for these little
points
so whereas before we had um a point that
was like each point was a one because it
represented one
iris one observation after we performed
the lateral inhibition procedure
um a given we're treating
one observation as one unit of weight
so when we're up weighting or down
waiting based on how close
an observation is to a border it's going
to
count as kind of more of an iris because
it's like more luminant
um and if it's on the the left-hand side
on the dimmer side it's going to count
as like less of an iris
so it's essentially a way to to weight
the different observations
before you run the clustering algorithm
um
so again as as in the image processing
part it is an overall
decrease in in luminance so essentially
you might say that everything's sort of
down weighted a little but it's all down
weighted by the same
general amount um and just the points
that are
bordering have that increased contrast
effect that's so nice
um once i had this set of
weighted points i submitted them to a
k-means cluster analysis again
um and it's again pretty subtle what i
would have liked to see is something
that was
very nice and clear and divided um
between
the the versacolor and the virginica um
and we we do kind of get that the
question is is it any better than when
we don't
weight the individual observations by
anything
um so to probe whether or not that was
the case
you can take these new cluster labels
that you get
once you've kind of adjusted the
importance of any given observation
before you you run the k-means cluster
analysis
um you can take these new cluster labels
that take that into account
and then you can train a random forest
classifier again
just on those cluster labels not on the
the sepal length or the people with
themselves just on
what the k-means algorithm thought based
on
the laterally inhibited weighted points
um you can see if cluster membership
after you've done all that
does a better job of predicting the
original variety of iris
and it's a little better it's
modest it's not great you know so
there's no way nowhere to go but up with
setosa
these are not raw counts these are
percentages versus color is about the
same
um but we do see that there is less of a
chance for virginia to be mistaken
for for versus color than there is
before
we have done the lateral inhibition
procedure um
we see a much nicer diagonal here we see
slightly higher values for uh
precision in the versacolor um
it's it's a modest change but i thought
it was really cool
that this this adaptation
that was developed over generations of
evolution with no real
teleological bent no intentionality to
it just
kind of what was the the quickest and
dirtiest solution to the
problem of blurriness at each generation
um
was able to be applied to this
completely different problem and
do a slight improvement on it you know i
didn't spend a ton of time
really refining this i think that
there's a potential to tune this up or
down
if we change the inhibition constant
we could also change the kernel you know
it's not as
we sort of talked about a little bit
earlier it's
the cool thing is that
we could convolve a kernel on a matrix
based on the i
in the first place we don't have to keep
exactly what evolution handed us
we could change we could fuss with that
kernel a little bit
so just returning up to here
uh again this is this is the the
biologically
the one that's pretty close to the
biological model um
if we were to to fuss with it to make it
more efficient then evolution was going
to make it
we could change this to an eight um we
could
uh in in certain in other kinds of
of sharpening kernels that i have seen
image processing
the the squares at the kind of northwest
and
northeast southeast and southwest points
are zeros and everything else is the
same
we can play with it a little bit but i
think it is really cool
that even when we're just taking
something directly from evolution we can
get
a little bit of an increase in
performance on this completely unrelated
data science problem
of just trying to do a better job of
distinguishing
classes of things in a multi-dimensional
space
so uh basically if you need to take away
from from this
this latter half of the presentation um
it's again this is all very modest and
and more playful than anything but i
think that
it's really worthwhile to kind of like
explore
um the inputs and insights we get
from other disciplines when we're trying
to find innovative solutions to problems
um and of course it's always important
to remember that
computer science owes a whole lot to
biology
um so that's my presentation
i would love it if you got in touch if
you had any questions i posted my
linkedin
and my email address please feel free to
get in touch i can pass you this
notebook
as well as the original slides but in
the meantime
i would be happy to answer any questions
that anybody has
uh what can you say about the efficiency
of this verse
versus some other unblurring or deep
blurring
uh algorithms i didn't directly explore
the different kernels that we would have
um so i'm thinking specifically of just
convolution by a kernel
um and i didn't compare it against any
other kinds of algorithms we would
we would look at um i think that
it's not likely to be this
new hidden silver bullet um that we can
now use and apply to a lot of our
multi-dimensional
cluster detection problems i think this
is more
a demonstration of how
these kinds of
self-organizing properties are
first of all present in nature and then
second of all
something that we can study nature to to
find
and then adjust ourselves so what i mean
by this is that i don't think
lateral inhibition in the visual system
is necessarily the most efficient way to
do it because that's not how evolution
works it reaches a local minimum
that's all it needs um a local optimum
and it doesn't need to find the most
efficient way to do things
um but i do think that by looking at
things like this we can potentially
discover
other kinds of maybe not perfect but
interesting solutions that biology has
come up with and then we can adjust them
ourselves
so it's a long walk for me to take to
say it's probably not the most efficient
way to do it but it's cool
um somebody asked in the chat if the
kenyan's cluster allowing algorithm
converges in fewer iterations when the
convolutions applied i didn't actually
look at that
um i would bet that it does that's what
i'd want to be true that that would be
related to the motivation for trying
this in the first place um is that it
would make it
more obvious to a clustering algorithm
um what the
the best centroid would be but um i
don't know
i would have to look good question
i have a biology question
um what is the vitreous humor good for
it mostly seems to just make it hard to
see things
it sure does um so i
it was it was passed on to me um
in my education as something we
inherited from when
vertebrates were marine animals
it's something to do with the way it's
it's it's
adaptation to vision underwater that
when we came out on deland we didn't
bother to get rid of we just
made this you know not
terribly efficient shortcut solution to
to band-aid over
got it
so a brief comment i think when you look
at the convolutional neural nets that
are used very frequently now
you'll find a lot of inspiration that
was taken from
the visual cortex and um
there might be some neat extensions from
the work you've done here in that
direction
yeah i think you're definitely right
i've um always thought neural networks
were cool
they have never been something that i i
tried to find a home for them in my
dissertation and i've tried to kind of
insert them into business cases at
molasses and it's it's always been like
the wrong tool for the particular
application
but i'm a neuroscientist by training so
i think they're the coolest
um and as i understand a lot of their
there are these convolutional layers
that i think are draw a lot of
inspiration as you said from
things in in the visual nervous system
and i wouldn't be surprised if there
were kernels that looked
quite like this when we're trying to
increase
contrast in an image
cappy just pointed out vitreous humor
helps maintain the shape of the eyeball
um that's a good point
but you wonder why we couldn't find some
other kind of fibrous way to do that
that was transparent you know it's one
of those things again where
every time um evolution doesn't come up
with the best answer to a problem
it comes up with to a a local optimum
i think i have i think that's
that seems to be all of the questions
but please do feel free to get in touch
uh if you would like the notebook or to
ask some more questions later
cool thank you very much eleanor this is
great thanks almost had a lot of fun
cool awesome all right
so so we will
go to our oh i forgot when i
don't share everything
i can't change the slide give me one
second
um i discovered this
in a very sad way one day all right so
we will move to our uh
to our next speaker now mary claire
thompson
and we'll learn about um prefect as a
data engineering
project workflow tool so i will
hand it over to you mary claire awesome
very clear just an interim reminder that
we are
we are recording this gotcha okay
cool cool all right
let me go ahead and do a screen share
you can see the messy contents of my
brain
okay and
there we go
okay so uh i want to start by thanking
the organizers for getting this set up
um thank you all
for attending virtually uh my name is
mary claire thompson
i'm a data engineer in the office of
information technology at duke
i work on the data analytics team
uh within oit um
we do well it's potentially not the best
name
anymore we used to do lots and lots of
data analytics
um our move what we were slowly making a
move
into more um engineering
focused work and then the pandemic kit
and that's all we cared about
so we're doing a lot of data engineering
right now
um before i started at duke
and i started in september of 2019
i was working as a software engineer and
data scientist
at a local ad tech startup
and then prior to that i was a data
scientist with overstock.com
so all of that being said um
i want to think about prefect as a data
engineering workflow tool
um in and the thing that i want to
um start with is telling you why we
landed on this tool
to help us manage all of our workflows
so why did we end up here um the answer
comes down to
finding a tool that fits our team
and so i want to start
with just a bit of information about our
team to help you understand where we are
and what we were looking for
so the analytics team in oit
is a pretty long established team but we
in the last few years have seen an
influx of new members
like i said i've only been on the team
for a year and a half
um my boss has been around for about two
years so
in addition to us a lot of other new
team members um
and with the onset
of the pandemic as i mentioned we really
saw the focus of our work
drastically shift we do we were doing
lots of analytics
and suddenly we needed to switch and
think about
data engineering almost full time
um so with that being said
we needed a good workflow management
tool
that could help us
manage all of the new jobs that we have
running
we had a legacy tool in place it was not
suiting our needs
and um it was very clear to my boss and
myself that we needed to find
something modern something that
could handle our very um
diverse needs and
we wanted to find a tool that would not
only
manage the um data engineer
engineering needs but would also be
something that was
suitable for a variety of people with
lots of different backgrounds all the
way from
heavy analytics work to people like
myself who
um spent time in ad tech so
we um
started this process by
thinking about some requirements and i
think
really the very most important one for
us was
that jobs be code
so as i mentioned before we had this
legacy workflow management
tool where when you create a job
you create it by building out
any user interface sort of this
drag-and-drop system
and that's fine but the
background what's living behind um
the ui is xml
and you can version control that good
luck figuring out what the changes mean
um this became a huge headache for my
boss i
um saw him get very
upset on a number of occasions about not
understanding how
an original job changed to become a new
job
especially when errors were cropping up
in these jobs as they changed
so it became very important to us that
we
um specifically be able to manage and
track
our job changes with git in a way that
made sense
so second as i mentioned we have a
variety of skills on our team
and we wanted some tool that was fairly
easy to learn
um so that would not be presenting a lot
of overhead for everybody
we specifically wanted something in a
language
that everyone um speaks so to say
sit and of course you know we're doing
lots of data analytics so python
was what that language needed to be
and then um straightforward management
was also a big uh a fairly important
thing for me this project became my baby
and so i'm the one who's managing the
tool
and i knew that it needed to be
something that was going to be fairly
straightforward to keep updated
um not too difficult to install and get
running
as you will probably realize very
uh distinctly throughout the course of
this talk i am a data engineer i'm not
an architect i'm not a systems engineer
so
needed to be something that was pretty
straightforward
and then obviously we wanted to handle
our modern data engineering needs
we are moving lots of data among a
variety of resources
cloud resources many duke local
resources
and then i
gave bonus points to tools that were
still under active development
um that came back that turned out to be
something that
was very helpful in the future and i'll
mention more about that momentarily
so we started looking at some contenders
one of the first things that we
considered and
almost immediately throughout was azure
logic apps
we in oit are using azure
and the microsoft folks suggested that
we look
at this tool and we did look at it
and it turns out that you manage jobs
through a ui again there's no code that
you can
version control and track changes and
know why jobs broke
i'm sure there are ways to do it that
are nice but we specifically wanted
code and git we also looked at nifi
and ran into similar problems we wanted
to be able to write jobs in python and
so
nifi wasn't going to work for us
when i started the process of looking
for the tool that we were going to land
on
i honestly thought you know i'm going to
look at some things but we're going to
use airflow
um i have previous experience with
airflow
um i know that tons of companies use it
and so
i honestly thought that was where we
were going to land
but i wanted to take some time to look
for other options see what was the
latest greatest
and as i was doing some research i did
run across prefect
and i thought it was pretty intriguing
um
it aligned with airflow and having a lot
of the
or in at least checking off a lot of the
boxes that we wanted um
just on an initial overview and so we
decided to give it a spin
and see what we thought
so in the contest between airflow
and prefects there as i mentioned are a
number of shared positives
they're both open source projects
prefect was recently open sourced i
think
in the first or second quarter of last
year if i remember correctly
you write jobs in python so again very
important box for us to check
they both have web uis that are pretty
nice
and i do want to pause here for just a
moment and emphasize
that there's a difference between a nice
web ui
and creating jobs in a ui
um it's really nice to have a good
ui for managing your jobs so that you
can
um take a look at logs for a job that
ran three days ago and failed
or so that you can um
get an overview of how long jobs are
taking to run perhaps see
if one is running a lot longer than it
used to
track historical changes um
again the thing that we didn't want in a
ui was being forced to use it to
actually create the jobs
so we want a nice ui for understanding
statistics
statistics about the jobs not for
creating them
i as a very mathy person i like
being able to represent my jobs as
directed acyclic graphs
so that's something that both airflow
and prefact offered
and then of course airflow had some
obvious pros as i mentioned
i've used it before in a previous
position and
it is the in my opinion the industry
standard
um a very well established solution
so then i started looking at prefect i
installed it started messing around with
it and
i found that there were a lot of things
that i really liked about it
um so the sort of silly one is that it
is very shiny
it looks really snazzy um every time
i've upgraded to the latest version it
looks
even a little bit shinier and that's
pretty nice
um obviously that's not the reason that
we chose it but it was a nice feature it
looks
very 2021
um and then as we wanted it is built
specifically with modern data
engineering needs in mind
um which you can see as you look through
the um the docs on docs.prefect.io
if you'd like to read more about this
there's a nice
blog post on the prefect uh blog that
talks about
the design decisions that were made in
building prefect
and um how those differ from those
for air flow
it is under active development um
and i'm going to jump ahead you already
know that i've been using prefact for a
while so i'll tell you why that has
turned out to be really awesome
there have been a number of occasions
where i just ran into something that
made me want to stab myself
in the face with a spoon there was just
something that was not working and
i couldn't figure it out and i went to
on each of these occasions every
occasion that this has happened
i've gone on to the prefect slack
channel asked questions
gotten answers from the developers of
prefect within
i'd say never more than an hour and
every single time they solve my problem
or at least got me to a point where i
knew how to solve the problem
so that has been phenomenal um
and then thinking about modern data
engineering needs
the uh the prefect api offers a variety
of
tasks that are specifically designed to
be integrated with
common resources many resources that we
use
here at duke such as azure
um so then
another really nice thing about prefect
is extensibility
um opportunity for customization
um if you'd like to make some changes to
the build just
alter the docker i
have not had to do this yet but i got
really close on one occasion
so it's nice to know that you can do
that if you need to
and then i think the thing
to me and to my boss that was perhaps
the most important in making the final
call
was the api so um
you know i spent a fair amount of time
in the api and
i really liked it i thought it was
really clean um
very simple and powerful and again
they're constantly adding new features
to the api
um there's both a functional and
imperative api which i like
i tend to try to write more functional
code
and lots and lots of conveniences
which i will talk about later when i
discuss the api
and um honestly i thought in comparison
with the api for airflow that
it was more straightforward much easier
to learn
um than the airflow dag definition
and so putting all this together we did
end up deciding to
go with airflow or go with airflow the
opposite of what i've just been saying
this whole time to go with prefect as
our
workflow management tool
so i noticed that i had a question here
this is a good place to maybe stop
and take a look at that question
which prefect license did you choose um
the one where there's not a pay for
thing
um and i will say more about that later
um
but remind me if i don't i probably will
um okay so with all that being said
um i want to spend some time talking
about the back end and the ui
then we'll switch and talk about the api
in a few minutes
so the back end architecture is lots of
docker containers
um there's a container that uh runs the
engine
the the prefect engine that is um keeps
the server up and running
you get uh a prefect agent the agent
is the little guy that's going to run
around and look for jobs and kick them
off
um keep track of them
you get graphql which allows you to
query the api
as well as postgres for managing your
job history
and then in terms of deployment this is
where i'm going to talk more about your
question
in terms of deployment there are a lot
of options
um so if you just want to put this on a
local machine
you can do that and it's free
um you don't have to it's not pay to
play
in this case um in fact most of the
options i'm going to mention
here are free
um if you happen to have yourself a nice
desk cluster hanging around you can
install it there
if you'd like to install it on your
cloud resources there are some
good options available there is built-in
functionality for
deploying in aws fargate
obviously you can just deploy on an ecs
instance if you'd like
more like the local single machine
deploy
azure ml support is coming soon and i'm
pretty
excited about that as again we are in
azure shop and this might
in some point in the future be an
interesting way for us to deploy
the only paid version
of prefect is the prefect
cloud managed service so this is managed
by prefect.io
um the nice thing about this is that
while it is pay to play for most
instances if you are a single developer
and you just want a chance to
mess with prefect and learn a bit
without actually having to install it
and manage
the server then you can actually use
this for free
so that's a great way to just get your
feet wet if you're interested in
learning a bit about it
um you can also deploy it with desk on
kubernetes
if you want to do that there are lots of
deployment um
options at the end of the talk i'll show
you a bit of the architecture that we
have
for our needs it has suited us well to
do essentially a single machine deploy
on a virtual machine in azure
and so again totally free and um
i again i'll show you some more about
that architecture later in the talk
so that's some of the back end for
prefect
now let's look at the shiny part the
user interface
voila so this is our um
production sort of front page there's
lots and lots of good information here
um
the front page gives you an overview of
everything that's going on
in prefect um so one thing that's
interesting that you can see right now
is that there is a job that is currently
running
you can look down here to see how long
it's been running which
job this is in terms of all of the
visuals you see here
the top bar gives us information just
sort of summary information about all of
the most recent runs
so i can see that oh about
two hours ago we had this job kick off
and last
run for about six minutes fifty months
seven fifty one seconds and it succeeded
again more summary information about all
the jobs that have run in the last day
um information about failed flows if you
have any
as well as scheduled runs runs that are
coming up
so i'm going to click on the flows
button up here and this will take us
to a summary page for all of the jobs
that we have installed in prefact
so this now gives us a breakdown
sort of job by job for what we have
going on in prefect
um for each of these jobs you can see
um whether or not there's a schedule
turned on you can toggle that if you
want to turn it on and off
you can see the project it's living in
the code version that you've got
when that latest version was created and
you can also see
run history for the job so the most
recent runs of this particular job
since this guy has a failure i'm going
to go ahead and click into
this flow or this job to take a look
at what's been going on here so this
particular job again
the front page for the job looks sort of
similar to the initial front page you've
got
summary information for the jobs that
have run recently
um some information that's a bit more
detailed about
this particular job as well as scheduled
runs
um in addition to all of that
i can take a look at the tasks that make
up
this job we'll say more about that in a
few minutes
recent runs of the job
as well as the directed acyclic graph
for the job and so i can take a look and
make sure that my logic makes sense
for building out this particular job
i can see the latest versions and again
summary information so i'm just drilling
down farther and farther into
information about this job
and i can if i want kick off a run
by hitting the run button or just the
quick run button up here
so one of the things that i mentioned
earlier that i really like
about uh prefect was all of the nice
conveniences that it gives you
and one of those is really um clean
nice built-in logging so i'm gonna hit
this job
that we see has failed
and drilled down to the particular part
of the job
that caused the issue
and i can go into the logs and
take a look at what happened and
see that it looked like it was some sort
of bizarre
database error that i don't understand
right now
but that's okay because it cleared
itself up anyway
um we found this really helpful the logs
are really clean
very well presented so it's just like
it's easy to dig through and find out
what went wrong
all right so that's the ui
quick overview in a few minutes i'm
going to
actually kick off a job and let you see
what it looks like when it's running in
the ui but i'll need to switch
to my um i'm on the production
server and i want to switch to the
develop one before we do that because
that's where my demo job is
so the next thing that we're going to do
is discuss
the api which as i mentioned earlier i
really like
so the core concepts for
creating a prefect job
i like to start by thinking about tasks
a task is just the basic unit of a job
you can think of this
as maybe just a definition in python
maybe a method in a class
the flow itself that's more like the
actual job
um it's really just a way to define
dependencies among the various tasks in
your job
and that's a really important concept to
keep track of
i'll come back to that momentarily
every flow and task has a state so
that's just the current status see this
is how much
cheaper um and
that can be things like that
sorry i think somebody might not be on
mute yeah
that can be things like pending
cancelled running um
etc
you're sure
pretty much
there we go good job team okay so
states uh it's just the current status
of
a flow or a task run and then state
handlers
are little bits of code that we use to
respond
to a changing state of a flow or
task run
um as i mentioned earlier we also get
really nice built-in capabilities for
logging there's also as one would want
good scheduling mechanisms
and nice ways to add parameters to your
jobs or flows
so this is sort of the core concepts
um there is much much more functionality
than what i've listed here
um quite a lot of very rich
functionality
um i'm only going to be discussing more
of the basics
here but um know that there's a lot more
out there and it's pretty cool
so the thing that i want to think about
for just a moment is
the idea of defining dependencies among
your tasks
it's a really important thing to do when
you are creating a job
so in prefect there are two ways to do
this
you can do it implicitly so let's say
that i've got
two tasks and task number two
takes the output of task number one as a
parameter
well if that's the case then you don't
explicitly need to say
task two should wait on task one prefect
knows
that that is the case and so that's just
an implicit way to define a dependency
but of course there are many times when
you aren't going to be
implicitly defining dependencies but you
still want task 2 to wait on
task 1 to complete before it runs
and in that case you um well there is
functionality in prefact to just
explicitly set task one as an upstream
task
for two and you'll see this little bit
of code
later in the talk um to do that
so this is sort of the explicit way to
define these dependencies
so when you're writing a flow um
maybe your first time you've never done
this before
maybe it's sort of the heuristic way to
think about doing this
would be to start by just writing a
python script just write whatever python
you want
and then take your definitions
and decorate them with the task wrapper
that
prefact provides for you so once you've
decorated a definition
with at task prefect
will know that that is a task it needs
to register and keep track of
and then you'll write your flow
definition so
you're essentially like defining the
dependencies among all of these tasks
one thing to note is that
tasks can run concurrently so you do
need to get your dependencies correct
um then
oh that's it so that's pretty much all
you have to do
and so to think about doing this i'm
going to give you
a very simple toy example very boring
example but we'll look at a more
interesting one in a moment
so we've got a very silly little script
here it
has a definition to generate a random
number and then
if you run the script you'll get your
favorite random number presumably
so it's really easy to take this script
and turn it into a flow
um so first you'll need to obviously
import
the correct prefact classes
and then take your definition and just
give it that wrapper
the last thing that you need to do is
write your flow definition
um which in this case is really boring
there are not any dependencies but
that's okay again we're gonna look at
something more interesting in a few
minutes
so as i mentioned earlier i liked the
api
a lot because it felt like writing
normal python
um you can see that for the most part
like these scripts pretty much look the
same
there's just a little extra
functionality there's a little extra
going on in the prefect version
if you wanted to take this prefix script
and actually get it on your server you
would add one little extra line of code
so you would add a line that says
flow.register so that tells prefect to
take this definition
and register it with the server and
now if you run the script on the
right-hand side of your screen
you actually will get the flow up in
the prefect ui and you'd be able to use
it
i saw that i have a couple of questions
so i'm going to stop and answer
those type of static checker that will
validate your prefect flow code
um i think
that there might be but
that is definitely something i've not
delved into so apologies i am not
entirely certain about that one
yeah i can't answer that question
is that is that my question about the
static checker yes yes
okay um in the the code snippet that
you're showing on the current slide
um is flow.register uh within the
with flow uh context
no or or is that it is not
so it's so does
it looks like lowercase flow with the in
in the with statement would no longer
exist
after after you you know
out dented uh to the left
hmm well it does
now that i think about it i'm not a
python person per se
so i hadn't thought about that but
somehow it magically works
um this is actually this is actually how
it's done
in the preface documentation as well so
okay so i guess it yeah it just lives
around there
but you're right i guess maybe that's
less pythonic but
it works anywho
good point okay just
i'm going to move on to a demo and that
means i'm going to take just a moment to
switch
the server context here let's see
so again i'm just switching over to my
dev server
all right cool that looks good
so let me share screen again okay
so we're going to dive into
a flow in a little more detail um
this is my dev server everything's
broken per usual
um so the flow i want to look at is
prefect demo
and um i'm going to show you what
the uh oops what the flow looks like
here
so i've got a final task to send an
email
and that has to wait so it has
dependencies it has to wait until this
task to get local data runs
as well as the task to get azure data
get azure data has to wait on these guys
to run so the get
creds task will have to run first
i'm going to just kick off a run so you
can see what this
looks like it's kind of cool the
timeline is flashy that's a new feature
but you can see
that um all of these tasks are running
and you can get
this comparison of how long each part of
the task takes
to run so
i want to think about um the code that
goes into building this flow
so again i have a task that's going to
get some text from a local file
and a task to get some credentials from
azure
or for azure that is and then
one to read some data from our blob
storage in an azure account
and all three of these tasks were
actually just
basic plain old python functions that we
just decorated so
these you would just write as you would
your normal python code
and similarly with the last task which
is to send an email
so i'm going to show you what not what
the particular details of
those definitions are but what how we
would stack these things together to get
the flow that you
saw a moment ago
so we have our opening statement that
defines the flow one thing i'll point
out that i'm going to come back to
later is information about scheduling
and adding state handlers
just as a sneak peek you can add those
into the
top level of the flow as parameters and
then you'll get a schedule picked up
you'll get the state handlers
so we
are going to run these separate tasks so
the get credentials task
which will then parse out to different
parts of the credentials
we had that task to get some local data
and another task to get data from azure
notice that this particular task
had to wait on a previous task to run
because components from
that or output of the task to get
credentials
are parameters here so that's an example
of the implicit
um definition of dependencies
the final task here is to send an email
which actually sounds like it just
showed up in my inbox
email server's a little slow um
and you will see here that i needed to
set
an explicit upstream task because this
output of the azure data function
doesn't show up as a parameter for
sending the email
and so that is a use of the
sort of the explicit setting of
one task as having a dependency on
another
so this is really straightforward it's
pretty easy to write this down
you can get a lot more complicated with
all of the features that prefect adds
uh so i do want to take a few minutes to
talk about things like
scheduling and state handlers that you
can see here
but again once you've registered this
particular flow with prefect
you end up with the
really nice page that you see here with
the flow registered and ready for you to
use
briefly for a question it's not clear to
me um
with these flows are they kicking these
jobs off in parallel where they're
parallelizable
but then passing the data explicitly as
python variables
like the results of the job like airflow
you tend to write to something
and then read it back in for the next
job if i remember correctly whereas this
appears you're passing
variables in memory yeah results yes
that is correct and that's one of the
that's actually something that they
discussed in that blog post that i
mentioned on prefact.io
um treating data as a first class
citizen i think
is the way that they put it
so um i want to talk a bit more about
the um the extra features that we could
use to customize the flow
so scheduling um is really nice
and easy i tend to use cron clocks or
um just cron notation and so you can do
that if you like
um the definition for a schedule that i
have set up here
is all i need to add to my flow
definition to have
a um to get this particular flow running
on the schedule that i've defined
um again there are a number of different
ways to define a schedule
so if you're interested take a look
state handlers as i mentioned are
just little ways to handle or to respond
to the changing state of a task or flow
run
you can pass your state handler as a
parameter to
either a registered flow or a task and
then your floor task will then um
pick up that save handler and use it if
your
if the floor task run works out to
um to have those particular changing
states
um the email handler that you saw me
refer to earlier
is one that i use in many of my jobs so
email handler will
just is it's just a tiny bit of code
that will send an email
to me and my boss if a job fails
and this is all you have to do to define
that handler
again you just pass it in as a parameter
to your flow or your task if you want to
use it
and so for this particular definition
there's more here under do some things
essentially it's
send an email but the
email handler just responds in this case
to
a new state that is a failure
but you can do many many more things
with this than my very simple example
you can also fine-tune task settings so
there are lots of ways to do this you
can use timeouts
retries you can add delays between
retries
as an example of doing this you can see
that i've got my get azure data task
i've
given it the at task wrapper and
i have passed a bunch of parameters into
the task wrapper
to again fine-tune those settings for
this particular task
i've set a two-minute timeout on the
task i've given it three retries
and a delay between retries of two
minutes and it looks like i've missed a
parenthesis
so apologies
again the built-in logging capabilities
are really nice
as a very simple example you can call a
logger or using
the notation that i've got here and then
use your logger as you would any other
logging tool and we've already seen an
example of
the formatting for the logs in the user
interface
and then parameterization is also a
really nice feature
that allows you to add required
non-required parameters with or without
defaults it's very very easy to set
these up in fact
i um the last time i gave this talk
right before the talk i was like i'm
going to learn how to use parameters
and i did in about 30 minutes and set
them up and got them running so it was
really nice to
um to just be able to do this very
quickly and not have to spend a bunch of
time reading documentation
really all you need to do to use a
parameter is
call the parameter class
and then rc my parameter here is good to
go and you can use it
throughout the flow i'll show you
in my um so this particular parameter i
named read
underscore container and i'll show you
in the particular flow where this shows
up
what that formatting looks like so this
is in this guy
so you can see read underscore container
shows up here and
so i can parametrize this run by filling
in um
the nulls here and hit the run button
so again this was just like it took me
like less than half an hour to
figure this out and get it up and
running which was very helpful as i had
a talk to give
so pretty nice
um then let's see what else do we have
okay advanced features which um
i'm not going to go into a lot of detail
with but i'm going to give you a few
ideas of some interesting advanced
features and there's a lot more out
there
that you can take a look at um so
i've only been showing you a single type
of task which is a python task the most
boring of all of the kinds
but there are lots of interesting tasks
built in
to prefect that or the prefect api that
will allow you to do do some pretty cool
things without too much setup which is
nice
so there are tasks for dealing with aws
data bricks interacting that is with
these services with redis
and actually many others there are quite
a few services that are supported
with lots of really nice specialized
functionality
there is also a lot of
interesting stuff going on with dynamic
dags so we have the ability to do task
looping
um as well as task mapping
um the mapping functionality looks it's
it's sort of a way to use mapreduce
um which is pretty cool
and again many more i think yes
many many more interesting things that
are in the works
or already available to use
so um that's the bulk of my talk
i did want to give you all an overview
of um the architecture that we're using
as well
as our ci cd integration
so a somewhat simplified view of our
architecture
is um this we have a virtual machine in
azure
that has our prefect or production that
is prefect installation
our on-prem get lab server is
dropping prefect flows on
the virtual machine and
then prefect is using them to move data
among
all of these resources and many more
again both local and cloud
there's a little more to this diagram as
i've mentioned we have a dev server
i didn't want to get too complicated
this is a good overview of what
um our setup looks like
and then one of my favorite things
about this whole situation is the
really nice cicd integration that we've
set up
which has been so seamless it's quite
nice
so the way that this is set up is that
a developer will make some changes
in pycharm or whatever their id is and
push those to gitlab
and then if that builds successfully in
gitlab
gitlab will push the code
to the virtual machine hosting prefect
and will also at the same time
register the flow with prefact
so then prefect living on that virtual
machine picks it up
and the developer can go to the user
interface and test
and make sure everything's working and
continue developing
and the process of pushing changes
to testing
the new flows in prefect
generally if if everything builds
correctly it takes
less than 30 seconds which is so helpful
um so that's something i've been really
happy with
um and that's it that's all i have to
say
so thank you all for hearing me out and
if you have any questions i'd be happy
to take them and probably not be able to
answer them
so
i had a quick question um so with the
parameters
if you change them in the ui does it
record
like the state that they were before
anywhere i um
so okay do you mean like if you change
them in the ui and then do a run
are those recorded in job information or
are you talking about like if you go
back
and want to do another run will it have
the original
parameters are they recorded somewhere
what that
runs parameters were i think i'm almost
confident that they are why don't we
poke around and see
what we see here actually i'm not sure
that i
have even run this oh no it looks like i
have
so let's see let's look at a run for
this particular guy
peculiar shrimp parameters voila
elsa yeah so you're there
very useful it is very useful
other questions
so sorry i have a question um
so when uh and you use this uh prefect
um that i i'm not quite familiar with
but uh
what's the um biggest difference if you
are familiar with airflow
is the biggest difference you
experienced that
using these two platforms um
i think probably the api um
they're very they're fairly different
similar enough that it's if you already
know airflow it's pretty easy to use
prefect but
um the prefect api is i think
probably the biggest difference um you
know as a developer that's the thing
that you're going to be focusing on the
most
um but i think that like the differences
are smaller
things such as um like the way that you
build
a uh an airflow dad versus the way that
you build a flow in prefect
um the fact as was mentioned earlier
that you can just pass data
from one task straight to another and
prefactors know like writing out
of data from between job or between
tasks
i think someone else had a question uh
yeah thanks uh thanks for the talk
um how do how do you and the team
manage uh python environments across
like when they're developing and then
also in prod
is there just one single environment or
do you have individual containers for
each job
um right now we have a single
environment
which could change based on um
what we need to build out that has not
been an issue
i think largely because
most of the jobs that we're writing
right now have
fairly similar um
uh fairly similar setups and
requirements
um so yeah right now it's one
environment
okay awesome thanks
very clear thank you for your talk um do
you have any
thoughts when you look into this about
how scalable how robust it is
when you're running a production
environment um
i think it's pretty scalable uh we
so as you've seen like we have we're
moving a fair amount of data back and
forth and we're doing totally fine
with sort of the single server deploy
um i think that it if you really needed
to scale this up putting it on desk
would be
awesome um and
i haven't tried that it's something that
i have i hope
to get to do at some point in the near
future
my understanding is that it's also
really nice
and probably very very scalable once you
get dasc involved
very clear i've got an interesting
question there they're
sile silos within uh the duke and duke
health
organizations um did you
ever have to work with other schedule
other schedules
uh or other systems where
you had to coordinate your run your jobs
with other uh other silos jobs
that weren't necessary that weren't
necessarily written in python
using prefect for instance so you're
absolutely correct
um that is a very fair statement about
duke
experience yes same
after my year and a half at duke um
so for these particular jobs
let's see i'm trying to think about
for these particular set of jobs
it has not been an issue um
it's certainly something that could come
up um
we have had more cooperation among teams
in the last uh well in the in the last
pandemic
um than before times which has been
great
so i hope that it will be less of an
issue moving forward
fortunately in recent memory i have not
had to
sort of coordinate among different
groups
um i do not know what that would look
like
honestly um so good question now i'll
stay up at night
worrying about that thank you sir
well thank you all so much for having me
i enjoyed talking to you all and um
thank you for your questions and your
attention
thank you mary claire this is nice
all right i don't i don't have
any volunteers yet for a lightning talk
does anyone want to give
a lightning talk
no lightning talks
this is one of those rare meetings that
i didn't think that i was going to be
able to to have any time
to either prepare or deliver a lightning
talk
i i apologize for not having a lightning
talk
i think you have given enough lightning
talks you should be allowed to have
a break sometimes
all right well if really no one
has has a lightning talk um i guess
that that means this is the end of our
of our program for today
thank you everybody for um coming out
and thanks very much
to our speakers um mary claire and
eleanor for for your talks they're very
nice
thanks man thanks ellie thank you all
thanks see you guys bye everybody